We just got the first teaser trailer for Wreck-It
Ralph 2 and hidden in there are some sneaky
Disney easter eggs including Aladdin's lamp,
Star Wars favourites Yoda and Chewbacca, plus
our first look at Ralph breaking the internet.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and this is my Wreck-It Ralph 2 trailer breakdown
for all the Disney and movie references you
might have missed.
Don't forget to let me know about any other
cool details you spotted in the comments below.
Thanks to footage shown at D23 last year,
we already know that the Wreck-It Ralph sequel
is going to feature loads of characters from
other big Disney properties, one of which
is Lucasfilm's Star Wars.
In fact, the D23 clip showed C-3PO and a bunch
of Stormtroopers, along with X-wings and TIE
fighters, all appearing in a sequence that
also included Disney's princesses, Dumbo,
and Iron Man!
Now, while we don't get to see those particular
Star Wars figures in the new trailer for Ralph
Breaks the Internet, there is a hidden hat-tip
to the galaxy far, far away in Mr Litwak's
office where, if you look closely at his shelves,
you'll see a couple of decorative plates featuring
none other than the little green Jedi Master
Yoda and Wookie co-pilot Chewbacca!
If you want to catch some other nice nods
to Disney movies, then check out the items
on sale in the background while Ralph and
Vanellope are staring at that cat painting
on eBay.
There's a Magic Lamp like the one that appears
in Disney's 1992 animated musical Aladdin,
which is getting a live-action remake next
year with Will Smith starring as Genie.
And there's also a Cast-Iron Frying Pan like
the one featured in Disney's animated movie
Tangled.
Although its eBay listing only says that the
pan is 'great for everything from frying chicken
to grilling a tortilla', it can also make
a very effective weapon, as Rapunzel, Flynn,
and the Royal Guard all show very well during
the course of Tangled.
"Oh, mama, I have got to get me one of these!"
When the arcade owner Mr Litwak uses his computer,
you can spot a reference back to the first
Wreck-It Ralph movie.
Take a look at the bottom right side of the
screen and you'll find a document called "Letter
to Nana".
In the first film, Litwak mentions his senile
nana several times:
"Mr. Litwak!"
"What's the trouble, sweetheart?"
"Oh, boy!"
"Look's like the game's gone cuckoo, like
my nana!"
"I'll have someone look at it in the morning,
but if he can't fix it, it may be time to
put old Ralph and Felix out to pasture.
Like my nana!"
"Sorry, sweetie.
Here's your quarter back."
"But what about the game?"
"I'll have someone look at it tomorrow..."
"But if he can't fix it, it might be time
to put old Ralph and Felix out to pasture."
"Like my nana."
The final pancake scene of Ralph feeding a
poor bunny so much it explodes seems like
a tease of Ralph doing what the movie's title
says: breaking the internet.
The little girl who was playing the pancake-milkshake
game until Ralph took over was certainly horrified
when she saw the bunny explode!
"Eat, eat!"
"Er, Ralph, you might wanna try feeding the
kitty for a little while."
"No!
The kitty gets the milkshake."
"The bunny gets the pancake."
"Eeehhhh"
This scene also reminded me of similar moments
in the Willy Wonka and Monty Python movies.
In Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory,
Violet Beauregarde blows up like a giant blueberry
after she takes Willy Wonka's experimental
3-course dinner gum.
And the Wreck-It Ralph scene is also a call-back
to Mr Creosote, the glutton from Monty Python's
The Meaning of Life, who explodes after he
finishes an enormous meal with an after-dinner
mint.
By the way, the little girl who Ralph traumatises
reminds me of Baby Moana from Disney's last
animated movie.
And it might be a way of including a Moana
easter egg to repay the Wreck-It Ralph easter
egg that appeared in Moana.
The older Moana will also be appearing in
a separate scene in Wreck-It Ralph 2 together
with a group of other Disney princesses.
Although we didn't get to see them in this
teaser, hopefully they'll be in the next full
trailer.
There's obviously going to be a ton of pop
culture references and online jokes in Wreck-It
Ralph 2.
A couple that pop up in this trailer are fake
prize scams and clickbait articles.
"Congratulations, you're a winner!"
"Really?"
"These 10 child stars went to prison!"
"Ooh."
"Number six will amaze you!"
"That sounds interesting."
Now, there's a good number of actors who've
ended up in jail, but I wonder if this could
be a jab at former Disney child star Lindsay
Lohan who's well-known for getting into trouble
with the law and has served time.
As a child, Lohan starred in Disney films
such as The Parent Trap and some of the studio's
TV movies, and, just last year, she suggested
on Instagram that she should play Ariel in
a live-action version of Disney's The Little
Mermaid.
Of course, given that Ralph and Vanellope
are exploring the internet, there's also bound
to be some more adult-themed jokes in the
movie.
I did notice that in the internet reception
hall, there's an IP Address Lookup area with
signs pointing to, among other things, "Unzip
Services" and browser "History Clearance".
And you can make what you want of that!
Just before I finish, I want to note that
we don't know a lot from this teaser about
what's going on back at the video arcade.
From the brief shots of a very empty parking
lot, and the way things are lit inside the
arcade, plus the fact that Game Central Station
doesn't look very busy, there's a sense that
the amusement arcade might be losing business
perhaps due to online competition.
And a brief synopsis of the movie indicates
that Ralph and Vanellope have ventured online
to look for a replacement part for her game
Sugar Rush.
So, let me know if you've got any theories
about what else you think might be going on.
So, what did you think of the teaser trailer
for Wreck-It Ralph 2?
And do you feel it looks as good as the first
film?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments
below and if you love animation, check out
my recent Pixar videos on Incredibles 2 and
Coco by tapping the screen right here.
And if you enjoyed this, don't forget to like,
share and subscribe to get all my new videos!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!